The joe rogan experience.
So I love it when your song was released and then it was destroying the charts
for Tlc and then you've gay TRL,
TRL,
and then did you,
were you forced to get rid of us?
I was forced to for 98 degrees.
That whole thing was,
it's a very,
um,
uh,
you know,
there's a,
there's a little bit of a intrigue here.
Yeah.
The went behind the story because there was,
you know,
some,
some things done TRL that we're,
we're not necessarily ever made public.
Right?
Like,
okay,
we'll fill me on the full detail.
What happened?
Like the l story,
the L and TRL isn't necessarily,
it's not necessarily live all the time.
What was your thought on any more?
No,
because it was the song,
what was the song and what happened?
Okay.
So we went to Seattle and we were filming bits in Seattle and we thought,
hey,
this would be funny to do this song called the bump bump song and my favorite
songs,
ridiculous idea.
And I would go,
and it was just a silly video of me going around from a Seattle saying,
my bum is on the cheese,
my bumps on the rail by bumps on the boat,
my bumps on the duck,
all this,
it was a silly sort of like a Dr Zeus style nursery rhyme,
rap and,
and the comedy of it was me out in the street sticking my ass on everything and
confusing people and filming the reactions,
right.
And singing the silly song.
And then we played it on my show and we said,
we want this to go to number one on total request live,
which is,
you know,
their countdown music show that they would have every night hosted by Carson
Daly.
And,
um,
so we played it on Seattle radio and it went to number one instantly.
This was when my show was on MTV.
It was,
it was,
it was really doing well,
show and empty.
The show is doing well on MTV people.
It went to number one,
people saw the absurdity of this song knocking 98 degrees,
Britney Spears in sync and whoever else was on the j Lo I think out of the,
out of the number one spot.
And so we went,
we played on the show,
we asked people to vote for it,
people voted for it.
It went to number one on Tuesday.
Okay.
The show I think aired on a Monday.
It went to number one on a Tuesday.
This is the song.
Yeah,
this was like fucking a huge,
this song was,
and this was the first uh,
song to be like,
this was right when MP three s just started.
So it was the number one downloaded song that year.
I thought you were,
I think 14 people downloaded.
No,
it was a,
no,
this was [inaudible] 99 to 2000 2099 so what happened?
So they squashed your song?
Yeah,
it went to number one on Tuesday.
Then on Wednesday,
on Wednesday it was numb number one again.
Okay.
And then on Thursday it was number one again.
And then we got a call on Thursday at the office and they're saying,
guys,
we want you to kind of play ball with us here.
And we're like,
well what's the deal?
They said,
well you know we need,
we need you to go on the show on Friday and retire the bum bum song and take it
off the countdown.
And we're like,
why?
It's we've got the number one song in America on MTV man.
Yeah,
right is amazing.
Right?
Money off this shit.
This is unbelievable.
Let's keep it number one.
They go,
well the thing is we've pre taped the show next week cause Carson's got to be in
San Francisco and all this stuff.
So we're kind of,
it's kind of like who we think's going to be,
right?
And we hadn't predicted you Erin the show on Monday and it instantly going to
number one.
So kind of screws up next week's pre tape,
which is all in the can.
So can you go on on a Friday and just retire it and we'll give you like a
retirement home plaque.
And here I was on MTV and I had my show on MTV and I didn't want to get fired.
Right.
Everybody's already mad at me about all this other shit.
Screaming at me all day about,
you know,
I want to suck milk out of a cow's udder cause I think it will be crazy.
Let's put it on TV.
And they're like,
can't you can't do that.
You know,
we're arguing nonstop.
It was like,
it was the most stressful time in my life.
And that's saying something because I'm pretty stressed out right now to now,
right now,
but most of the time,
you know,
and so,
so I'm on the show and I'm getting yelled at all the time by everybody.
Everyone's always screaming at each other,
trying to like,
you know,
make the show crazy or make it less crazy.
And then,
so,
you know,
I played ball,
I went and I got a nice plaque and it,
you know what?
I'm not even to be honest with you,
not eat well.
Yeah.
You know,
I think of it now.
I think,
you know,
we could have rode that thing a little further.
I could have put out record,
I probably could,
you know,
had some fun with that.
But um,
yeah,
that's what happened.
That's what happened.
That's,
that's interesting man.
You got Fox got fucked by the corporations.
Yeah,
exactly.
It was,
it would make sense to other,
they would probably cost him a fuck load of money if they had already pre tape
thing there reshoot five shows and it's like,
you know,
how crazy is that?
And now you find out what their rankings are like total,
they paid them up.
It probably had deals with the record company.
Like we need to push 98 degrees and a here's $100,000.
We need to get to do that.
Probably it's so that's illegal.
I mean that's,
Delphine did that.
They did that.
I never heard any just making shit up.
No,
no.
I'm just throwing shit on the table.
I have never did anything like that.
I think it was just basically,
it was a very strange week.
And,
uh,
they,
they'd sort of,
if it wasn't for that week,
that song could have stayed on the countdown.
And because I can't,
but you know,
I've,
I've told that story before.
I don't think anyone at MTV cares anymore about that.
Well,
why would they care?
Fuck fucked you.
You're the one supposed to care.
You have got paid.
So drive in that fucking song right now.
Yup.
In the form of a Red Ferrari.
Yeah,
that's true.
I'm saying you could be rolling with a big fat diamond encrusted watch,
letting bitches know.
And they'd be like,
Tom Green.
How'd you get so rich bum,
bum,
bum bum song.
Okay,
you ready?
Of course recording.
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck's on?